tous les jours après le travail cédric
cycliste amateur va s'entraîner chez lui
pour le moment il faut que je travaille
dans mon bureau mais tous les jours
quand décoché ni ma journée de travail
je continue mes entraînements dès que
possible et bientôt à l'extérieur
j'espère le champion a très vite
abandonné l'idée de refaire 100 fois le
kilomètre autorisé dans le quartier
alors il rejoint son appartement par
l'escalier ça prépare les mollets
aujourd'hui direction riche monde etats
unis pour une séance d'entraînement
bon maintenant je laime singer chaque
semaine
cédric fait à peu près 15 heures de vélo
plus de 1000 km quand j'arrive
j'installe mon vélo ici je le pose là
bas pour avoir un peu plus de place
j'installe tout le matériel j'allume
ensuite l'ordinateur et je branche
surtout c'est le home trainer connectés
donc c'est grâce à ras assure mme
trauner là que je vais avoir mes puis
centre d'entraînement pour pouvoir
travailler avec le logiciel car le
logiciel fourni par le coach restitue
les paysages ajoute de la difficulté
dans les côtes à un peu moins dans les
descentes
on a le mont ventoux qu'on peut monter
et on peut monter l'alpe d'huez en
virtuel de chez nous mais on peut le
faire
ne surtout pas oublier le ventilateur
pour faire un peu de vent et un bidon
d'eau pour la route
c'est parti pour une heure sur les
traces de peter sagan aux championnats
du monde 2015
après le premier confinement pour sa
première saison au club de vineuil
cédric est monté quatre ou cinq fois sur
le podium et a remporté un titre
régional
il se prépare pour une saison de cyclo
cross
c'est pas du tout la même chose on a
moins de vous dans le visage en sang -
le froid mais ça reste de l'entraînement
et quand on est sportif et qu'on veut
performer que l'entraînement soit à
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur l'important
c'est de s'entraîner et de rester en
forme même si des dehors il fait beau il
fait soleil ici dedans il fait soleil
aussi et je m'amuse autant pour
l'instant en attendant de retrouver les
copains du club sur les routes du loir
et cher il roule avec des cyclistes de
toute la planète souvent confinées eux
aussi on peut faire également donc des
courses virtuelles et l'a donc que c'est
une compétition avec 150 200 300 j'ai
fait des courses jusqu'à 1200 personnes
en même temps
pour lui c'est presque un autre sport
j'ai fait des très belles courses à
niveau national et international
j'ai fait plusieurs championnats de
finale en championnat de france
je n'avais pas le niveau pour aller au
niveau de sude en crète professionnelle
mais ça n'empêche pas que le vélo ça
reste ma passion et que je fais
certainement faire le plus possible
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin